[Music]
today I want to tackle the topic of
toxic masculinity we are all guys here
and we get to take our own perspectives
and tell the world what are we trying
can I just say are we trying to get laid
through this also what is toxic
masculinity
okay so right here I'm alive because
just not here so I'm not sure I don't
know what that means
toxic masculinity is defined by
adherence to traditional male gender
rules that consequently stigmatize and
limit the emotions boys and men may
comfortably express while status another
emotions such as anger
now that's very [ __ ] vague yes so I
went in ahead and went through some
articles and basically they're trying to
define what this is and one person or
this person who wrote this defines is as
a toxic masculinity is a narrow and
repressive description of manhood
designating manhood as defined by
violence sex status and aggression it's
the cultural ideal of manliness where
strength is everything while emotions
are weakness where sex and brutality are
yardsticks by which men are measured
while supposedly feminine traits which
can range from emotional vulnerability
to simply not being hyper sexual or the
means by which your status as a man can
be taken away is this so since it's
toxic masculinity who are the victims of
this would it be women and men or sure
in this article they're saying that it's
not a war on men necessarily but that's
what it sounds like yeah it sounds like
that but it'sit's basically it's like
saying discussing toxic masculine are
bad or evil and a term is not an
assertion that men are naturally violent
in fact this conversation was started by
men so it was inspired by a feminist
movement that had done well yeah it says
it wasn't started by men right it wasn't
started wait wait wait no no it was
started by men sorry the conversation is
Jason Katz TED talk on the subject is a
useful starting point so I feel
girlfriend's yelling at you could she be
exhibiting toxic masculinity masculinity
- oh just a we call it Amanda she's
telling you as a man to minimize your
your emotion yeah because you're a man
so yeah so it's a it's a school of
thought it can be perpetuated by both
males and females I see and generally
what I took from the small research that
I did is anyone that is a part of this
school of thought and thinking is a part
of toxic masculinity so you could be a
mother telling your son like hey don't
be a [ __ ] yeah don't don't don't you
know don't be girly
stop playing with dolls but don't be a
[ __ ] is such an unfair I don't know man
cuz to me don't be a [ __ ] doesn't mean
like don't express yourself that's what
it means to me like don't be top don't
be top with my little obstacles right
what I guess I'm people but I think it
also depends on the context of ways
given to that person because I think
some people it's like when they're being
told ed don't be a [ __ ] or whatever it
it does relate to their feeling that
doesn't everyone
but that's why when we generalize things
like toxic masculinity it sounds like an
epidemic that's happening to everybody
right I don't like terms like that
because I do you know it's like this
like it's not like I'm gonna go ahead
and disagree that things like that exist
but when you create these blanket
statements you create a boogeyman
situation where you like that sounds
like toxic machspeed you know what it
sounds like to me the gay agenda
yeah yeah right it's the same [ __ ] to me
yeah it's the same [ __ ] yeah and I don't
know like then it and then then it's
difficult to define because now it's
like what is this like for example
another thing would be racism right some
people believe that it doesn't really
exist and some people believe that it
does or whatever but then it's easier to
objectively define what racism is and
you can battle it out in court like was
this a hate crime was this a racist act
right
but with toxic masculinity I don't think
you can really define clearly
objectively and it can't hold up in
court
yeah well it also it also depends on
like how they're using it to like it's
not all masculine things are necessarily
bad by definition
but that's why they put the word toxic
right so that but then it's like but
then I feel like the people that are
using that term sometimes use it as a
bully receivers are all of like
masculine masculine features wise that's
the mostly what I see it yeah it's like
it it's a misappropriation of that but I
would still agree with like the original
assertion which is that like there are
certain like cultural things that like
as men we were told like hey you know
don't you know deal with your feelings
yeah you're right yeah yeah and you
could take something too far always
because when I hear toxic masculinity it
almost sounds like you're too much of a
breadwinner and I'm like what a weird
word in general to mean too much though
because I have I ever said like don't be
a [ __ ] to anyone it's never about their
feelings like if someone is coming to me
and they're crying
I'm never gonna dismiss their feelings
if I ever said don't be a [ __ ] to
someone or even to myself
it's usually an obstacle that I kind of
look through with the magnifying glass
and it's actually not that big of a deal
and I need it like it depends cuz if I
saw if somebody come to me and they're
crying and they're crying because they
took off the VR headset in their hair
then yeah I'm gonna laugh about it but
but if it's like I'm crying because
something just happened as serious it's
different yeah so there is there's a
funny time to every now yeah but we're
also around a lot of intelligent guys
that also respect women right like so
for example I think you know like both
TIFF and Gio have said that when they're
walking the streets in Mexico they get
constantly catcalled
and it's very different from you know
maybe you know or even the streets of
East LA actually right right so that's
way more frequent maybe in that culture
to be openly like sexually aggressive
yeah right so I think that's what
they're moreso talking about is that
mask you machismo masculine culture
maybe well that's not even masculinity
to me because masculinity doesn't matter
yeah you're protecting windows we
protecting yes that's what masculinity
is so I what they're saying the toxic
bare skin right so it's yeah this is
this is the baddest version of
masculinity where you're literally
telling other dudes to shut the [ __ ] up
of other feelings and you're telling
chicks that there's a putting other
people down for being in touch with like
emotions and whatnot right well what
ends up happening is that
it's I think it's like you group all men
and we get hit in the crossfire and it's
like you guys are like this it is like
wait wait wait hold on I'm not a part of
that group right more dude I mean
remember the rape culture stuff on
campuses where everyone said like that
the Duke lacrosse team raped a bunch of
chicks and they didn't like that all got
like in court that was found to be not
true but the media made this big [ __ ]
thing with a Duke lacrosse team was a
bunch of rape culture guys and like
they're all slapping five about how they
raped some girl and like none of that
gets you know reported on later where
it's like hey this didn't happen it's
just like they everyone in the movement
just kind of moves on because it's not
part of their excuse for why men suck so
or women's uprights and [ __ ] so so this
whole idea that like you can just
generalize a group that's the problem
that I think I think so too because what
ends up happening is people obviously
are growing up in shitty situations
right like maybe they have shitty father
figures or men around them and then they
finally stand up and they go the world's
full of shitty men not realizing hey
maybe your family in your situation was
[ __ ] up not everyone has shitty role
models growing on right and I think
that's what people are doing is though
they're reacting to anecdotally like
what happened to them personally and
they go the world has shitty men I mean
that's that's pretty now I feel like
there are a lot of for a lot of people
it's cuz if you've had bad experiences
like that then yeah it's gonna skew your
worldview just like how we have all
collectively our own bad experiences
maybe one particular group that like
kind of makes us you know it's a little
bit skewed towards that
yeah but the goal is to be more
intelligent oh yeah totally
humans right so but when we have these
terms of toxic masculinity or whatever
we stoop right back down I guess I'm
just empathizing with where the feeling
comes from I don't think it necessarily
works as a blanket statement but I think
that like to understand why someone
would reach that conclusion like I can
but you know what provides the inside
you know what I think it's kind of
[ __ ] up is how we generalize people in
categories we're like so for example I'm
very good emotionally at analyzing
situations and some people say including
my own
a group of friends sometimes they say
that I have feminine energy because I'm
able to diagnose emotional situations
yeah yeah and that's part of what's
[ __ ] about our our group of people
in the world where everyone's like if
you are able to diagnose something
emotionally that's considered feminine
if you have any touch of emotion it
makes you feminine right why can't it be
masculine to do that is is alpha males
or males that are on a higher totem pole
of the hierarchy in the animal system
and in the human system right they
actually possess empathy because with
empathy they can read their team their
tribe and they can hit the problem areas
and work socially to make sure that the
team stays high and morale and things
like that so having being able to read
emotions is actually a very high skill
for a leader to have right but we are
not chimpanzees we are we are we are men
and so the idea that a man who's able to
diagnose something does not make him a
chimpanzee it makes him a man I think
and so the idea that masculinity can be
categorized such a way we're like hey if
you're able to emotionally evaluate a
situation that's not manly is [ __ ] up
yeah and that's part of what I think
toxic masculinity it actually is right
men can't possess this - the traits of
this you're not able to do that men
can't communicate like that men are too
[ __ ] brawny and [ __ ] we punch
walls too much what about men that wear
eyeliner is that okay no unless you're
in a pirate movie and then it's actually
very sexy
have you heard of the theory of the
warrior farmer No so I was listening to
this podcast of a male feminist and I
think he wrote a book on all this down
but he's like he's like male Finny's
feminism how I used a movement to get
really [ __ ] late my girls with armpit
hair I thought this was [ __ ]
interesting right because you know in
academics they try to go through like
biological characteristics and societal
and cultural to answer why our society
is like this and one of the theories
that backs this up is the is the idea of
women are actually they have the freedom
to express and explore humanity better
than men because men had to totally yeah
historically because men had to go to
war so then you have to train men where
they're hunting or have yet to have less
empathy so just as evolutionary and
maybe even culturally we were taught to
kill if you're always crying about the
animals and the people that you're
killing you're not gonna make a really
good killer ain't not gonna be efficient
right yeah so but for us we have to be a
farmer and then we also you know so so
we're in society and we're working and
we're normal normal like uh non-violent
human beings but when it's time to
protect and go to war we have to turn
that on right whereas women always had
the luxury or not the luxury but the
ability to stay protected and be a human
being and a nurturer so their color
palette of expressing emotions and
reading emotions got to develop because
also they were the the nurturers of our
society so they had to read what a baby
needs without speaking right and they
had the benefit of calling of Politan
magazine Mary Claire you know all the
things that men don't daddy fair yeah
yeah we can't get these sorts of
periodicals right we don't have the
means to do that and so that's part of
what's really [ __ ] up cavemen back
then reading well that's one of the
things right is that they're saying that
they had they have that time with the
baby and they have the hours of training
in the in the nonverbal communication
even amongst themselves and then men on
the other hand we go out and we have to
grab food and we have to kill and we
have to be more like evolutionary that
way so when we came back we weren't able
to communicate and read emotions at the
level that they were able to now that
our society has kind of shifted yeah
where we don't really have you know have
to hunt like that anymore Wars because
of tech inside kind of is a great
equalizer yeah
now we have these kind of conversations
now about like hey that those roles
don't really apply so much in this
module but now if you're a man imagine
the pressure you have to be like Ryan
Reynolds you have to be almost hair
and little and let's talk about the
unrealistic expectations of men thank
you with [ __ ] you know how hard it is
to get a six-pack although you know how
hard it is to make thirty percent more
thank you
nobody says it I would love to be a
stay-at-home dad man
[Music]
you